mon grand père qui avait connu la guerre
de 14 le dise non mais rien n'est grave
dans la vie avec la mort qui est
irréversible j'avais toujours cette
petite phrase en tête
je crois qu'il m'arrivait un coup dur
que la ville frappée fort que les notes
étaient pas bonnes que j'étais exclu de
telle ou telle chose
je me disais c'est pas grave je suis pas
mort alors est-ce que c'était facile de
parvenir jusque là au statut de dire de
d'artisans de chefs des chefs
d'entreprise n'ont pas été faciles
il a fallu d'abord travaillé beaucoup
s'imposer à accepter les échecs le
premier échec a été extrêmement des
structures ans a été l'échec scolaire
enfants tout petits à l'école primaire
je voulais pas aller à l'école primaire
eu ma grand-mère me disait toujours tu
sais les riches ils ont le savoir donc
ils ont le pouvoir
si tu sais pas lire écrire et compter
ils vont nous voler donc par esprit de
sécurité personnelle je suis allée
quasiment sonné l'école pour apprendre à
lire à écrire et à compter mais je
pensais que j'avais fait le tour de ce
qu'il fallait apprendre pour être un
homme
donc c'est loin d'être suffisant mais
quand j'arrive au collège on dit ah non
ça c'est pour les petits maintenant faut
faire des mathématiques modernes et là
je ne comprends pas avec qu'est ce que
je vais faire des mathématiques modernes
pour payer ma baguette de pain ou
pourrait faire du sport ça ne servira à
rien donc j'y vais pas mais la spirale
des quartiers on la connaît un selo
l'escalier le hall b contre le haut
c'est celui ont joué les gros bras et
c'était uniquement salle l'aller
boudreau la cité des bois l'abbé c'était
c'était le tour de biceps plutôt que le
tour de tête quant à elle qu'elle a été
la suite pour vous en sortir
la suite c'était de me tourner vers des
gens qui m'apportait du soutien donc
bien sûr la famille mais aussi le sport
et c'est vrai que dans le sport j'ai
trouvé un cadre éducationnel qui m'a
fait prendre confiance en moi et qui m'a
mis en situation de comprendre mes
échecs où je dois vous allez apprendre
chuté vous allez apprendre a chuté pour
mieux vous relever même voir pour
dépasser le point de chute
et bien cet apprentissage là dans le
faire pour apprendre ou s'est aperçu que
dans la vie c'est la même chose si vous
restez bloqué sur la chute
vous n'avez pas anticiper un petit peu
les choses pour pouvoir vous relever
les restés piégés par cet échec mon cas
personnel
j'ai ma première entreprise a été un
échec
j'ai obtenu une étoile au guide michelin
mais économiquement
je n'ai pas tenus je n'ai pas tenu la
distance et bien j'ai regardé dans cet
échec
mon incapacité à savoir gérer une
entreprise à l'époque mais par contre ma
capacité à faire parler de moi dans mon
style de cuisine
bien évidemment j'ai gardé cette
capacité à faire parler de moi et a
continué à vouloir faire une cuisine
d'auteur et en même temps en parallèle
d'aller apprendre toutes les techniques
qui m'aurait servi qui peuvent servir à
créer la prochaine entreprises donc je
suis allé vers le management vers la
comptabilité la stratégie d'entreprise
et ensuite et bien chez greffer à ce que
j'avais gardé de positif dans le premier
échec et j'ai amené une compétence
supplémentaire est la deuxième
entreprise a été une réussite
thierry marx le chef cuisinier prépare
ici 24 milles couverts par an le chef
comme on l'appelle a réussi à obtenir
deux étoiles au michelin
le sol en gironde voyez que l'échec est
un moteur assez fort encore une fois et
je pèse mon propos en disant cela si on
n'en fait pas une dramaturgie si les
chèques ne vous a pas tués mais il n'y a
pas de raison ne pas repartir
et là aussi nous occidentaux il faut
apprendre cela et il n'y a pas à
condamner les chèques
moi je me souviens quand j'ai commencé
les scream au sabre au japon j'avais un
professeur qui nous envoyait tous tous
les ans ses voeux un tel oubli et il
disait je vous souhaite une bonne année
avec beaucoup d'échecs jouer sa
formidable parce qu'il disait si vous
êtes capable de faire l'analyse de vos
échecs
vous allez très très bon mais si vous
n'êtes pas capable de vous entraîner de
provoquer l'échec d'aller à l'échec
d'aller chercher les chèques vous ne
progressait pas